Speaker 1: All right. Let's look at a couple
of interviews from the last 24 hours from the
two men who, if they both run, are the likely
frontrunners in the 2024 Republican primary.
We're going to start with Ron DeSantis and then
look at Donald Trump. Ron DeSantis is on what,
according to many, is a very ill advised trip to
Asia right now, flooding and gas lines in Florida,
all sorts of problems that are self-inflicted,
quite frankly, by Ron DeSantis. And he was in
Japan yesterday, and I believe now in Korea,
really a profile in courage in South Korea that,
as you might imagine and during the HANNITY hour
last night on Fox News, which I guess coincides
conveniently with the time difference with where
Ron DeSantis is, Ron DeSantis was interviewed. Now
there's a logistical problem and then there's
a substance problem. The logistical problem,
as you will notice, is that somehow they
set DeSantis up. Facing the sun. And he's
squinting the entire interview. He looks visibly
uncomfortable now. DeSantis often looks visibly
uncomfortable, even in a well-lit, cool room.
But here he looks extra uncomfortable. So I
don't know what you know. This was a scheduled
interview. Why? They have him staring into the
sun? I don't really know. Maybe it's because Trump
stared at the eclipse that time and they wanted
to do the same thing. Unclear. But DeSantis
generally is just not really understanding
how to properly answer basic questions. In this
clip, HANNITY asks DeSantis What happened to your
relationship with Donald Trump? Here's his answer.
Speaker 2: The last time I interviewed President
Trump, I was there in 2018, and I always saw
the two of you as friends. And I said to him.
Speaker 1: You guys were friends.
Speaker 2: It's a very simple question.
I asked him. I said, What happened? And I think
it's only fair to ask you the same question. What
do you think happened?
Speaker 5:
You know, I enjoyed supporting him when he
was president. We worked really hard for his
reelection in Florida, and I always had a good
relationship with him. And then once the midterm
election happened, he started taking shots at
me. I didn't really do anything to do it except
do a good job. But that's fine. I mean, Sean, you
know, when you're making things happen, you take
incoming from a variety of targets. So that's
just the nature of the business. And I'm happy
to I'm happy to stand strong and do what's right.
Speaker 1: All right, guys, I don't think DeSantis
can do it. This is such a weak answer by the
standards of what Republican voters want. Think
of it now. DeSantis isn't wrong. Listen,
the sentence is accurately pointing out.
He used to like me. Then he stopped liking me when
it became clear that the Santos wasn't backing
down from challenging Trump in 2024. This is how
it all started. Remember that? What happened was
DeSantis was asked, Would you consider running
in 2024 and would you commit to only doing it
if Trump isn't running? And DeSantis didn't rule
out, Now, I might run. Even if Trump Trump runs,
I might challenge Trump. This was seen as disloyal
by Trump, and that's why all of this started. So
DeSantis, his assessment is 100% correct. Trump
just started going after me, and I'm not going to
get involved in it. This is so pathetic and weak
looking from the standards of these Republican
voters, he's basically saying, I don't know,
he just went after me and I'm doing nothing.
Now, you and I might say you need someone taking
the high road. In fact, it would be better to
have someone who's not even involved in this
nonsense, someone like a mitt Romney or a Liz
Cheney or whatever else the case may be. I'm with
you on a personal level, but this is weak stuff.
This is not going to if you think Trump's got 52%
right now, DeSantis has 24. And in order to win,
DeSantis has has to figure out some way to get
up to and beyond 50%. This isn't going to help
him. Just when he started it that he sounds whiny,
he sounds pathetic. And the interview continued.
And it really isn't great for DeSantis here.
Asked again about the the attacks and he says,
I'm just going to do what's right.
Speaker 5: That's fine. I mean, Sean,
you know, when you're making things happen, you
take incoming from a variety of targets. So that's
just the nature of the business. And I'm happy
to. I'm happy to stand strong and do what's right.
Speaker 2: All right, Governor, have a
great trip. We appreciate you joining us.
Speaker 1: Okay. And I thought we actually had new
stuff there. But it seems sort of like a retread
of a lot of the same stuff. So this is not a guy
who you see and you say, wow. Projecting strength,
projecting confidence, projecting an inspiring
and electric alternative vision to what Trump
gives us. Hey, you know what? I was a Trump
person. Maybe I'll go for DeSantis instead.
It's maybe good enough to kind of clean up the
hangers on and the dregs of the opposition to
Trump that is already there. But it's not going
to coalesce people around you and restructure the
dynamic of this primary in a way that's going to
let you win it. It's just not going to do any of
that. So now the question for Desantis's, does he
even announced, does he try to wait until 2024?
Does he forget about the presidency
altogether? Does he risk possibly
humiliation, quite frankly? I mean, it
is totally he really doesn't seem to
have what it takes. And if he enters this
race with Trump at 52 and DeSantis at 24
and doesn't have some way to strongly gain
support, he could end up truly humiliated. And
it would be an entertaining watch from a political
strategy standpoint, be sort of a strange
thing. So that's the DeSantis interview from
yesterday. Let's now look at the Trump interview